some Peter's square at the Vatican
because Mass has ended obviously Easter
Sunday today and Pope Francis is
delivering a speech that pontiffs
give on Christmas and Easter it's called
excuse my pronunciation of that but it
means to the city and to the world and
the message is frequently an occasion to
decry Wars and injustices around the
globe including religious persecution
let's just have a listen in but it is in
Latin conflicted
foreign
Palestinians
[Music]
that's according to Vatican Security
Services that was at the beginning of
the mid-morning mass at the beginning of
the Easter ceremony Pope Francis
sprinkling holy water and he sounded a
bit tired and they're coughing a bit
there he does sound a bit tired still
doesn't he is he recited ritual words in
Latin he's got a canopy on the edge of
the steps on the Square Sheltering him
he's obviously back in the uh public eye
12 hours only 12 hours after what was of
long Easter Vigil ceremony in Saint
Peter's Basilica the night before he's
still recovering from that bronchitis
that saw him hospitalized for three days
he's 86 and he skipped the traditional
Good Friday procession at Rooms Coliseum
because it was unseen as unseasonably
cold there but Sunday is Breezy you can
see it bright and the temperatures have
quickly gone up let's have a so that's
live let's have a look at the latest
pictures Pope Francis obviously he's not
as mobile as he was he's now 86 and he
was taken around in his rather
spectacular G-Wagon
around Saint Peter's Square greeting all
those 45 000 people there for Mass on
Easter Sunday and a happy Easter to you
too if you are celebrating